today we're going to be speaking with
Matt Desmond who's a professor of
Sociology at Princeton University and
also author of the book poverty by
America really appreciate your time
today looking forward to this
conversation me too thanks for having me
so when we talk about poverty in the
United States we know that on average
and we can Define average a few
different ways the United States is a
very very rich country we've all heard
you know you put Bill Gates in a room
with poor people the mean net worth gets
very high but it doesn't really
represent the situation for everybody
other than Bill Gates in that room is it
a mathematical reality that even though
there are very rich people in the United
States and that sort of skews these
averages poverty is still very high do
we need to go beyond that to really
understand the source of it
the United States stands alone is the
richest country in the world with the
worst poverty so our child poverty rate
is double that of other peer Nations
like Canada South Korea Germany Angus
Deaton The Economist estimated that over
5 million Americans live in abject
poverty by global standards getting by
on four dollars a day or less and look
one in three of us live in homes making
fifty five thousand dollars or less a
lot of those homes aren't considered
officially poor but what else do you
call trying to raise two kids on 55k in
Boston so there's a giant amount of
insecurity in poverty in this Richland
when we think about poverty part of what
we have to talk about is how we're
measuring it and as you're talking about
there are people who by the definition
in the United States aren't poor but
that the Practical day-to-day realities
certainly mirror poverty as we
understand it can you talk a little bit
about how the definition of poverty in
the United States has changed over time
so there's a lot of different ways to
measure poverty researchers do not agree
on what the best measure is you know for
me one way to measure hardship is just
to measure hardship and so you can look
at something like evictions they're up
20 since 2000. look at the share of
families visiting food pantries up 19
since 2000 the number of our homeless
school kids is up 74 since the Great
Recession there's a lot of incredibly
troubling signs that poverty is not only
persistent in America but growing you
know the poverty line is a is a pretty
flawed measure but it also tracks pretty
well with those hardship measures the
government introduced another measure
called the supplemental poverty rate
yeah supplemental poverty measure in
2011 and it counted for a lot of kind of
government programs the official poverty
measure ignores but it also accounted
for like housing costs and Regional
variation and cost of living which the
official poverty measure also ignores
and when they release that line that new
poverty line the country officially
gained three million more poor people
actually because any reductions in
poverty offset by counting Aid were more
than kind of canceled out by counting
Rising housing and medical costs
I want to really delve into one of the
aspects you write about in the book that
goes above and beyond defining some of
these terms establishing what the
situation currently is and what it has
been and you talk about how affluent
Americans knowingly or unknowingly uh
contribute to poor people remaining poor
and this may be a difficult thing for
for some people to hear and and to
understand can can you talk a little bit
about that and how you lay out the case
for The Knowing or the unknowing aspect
of that
I ran across this line by the novelist
Tommy Orange
um and it goes like this these kids are
jumping out of the windows of burning
buildings falling to their gaths
and we think that the problem is that
they're jumping
and when I read that sentence I was like
man that sounds like the American
poverty debate you know for for hundreds
of years really
our Focus has been on the poor on the
poor themselves
the jumpers you know we should have been
focusing on the fire Who lit it who's
warming their hands by it and many of us
when we have that kind of conversation
and we want to talk about the guy that's
just a little richer than us or a lot
richer than us but the book is really
trying to get a lot of us and by us I
mean those of us that have found some
security and privilege in this country
to really yeah looking hard in our lives
and realize how we're connected to the
problem and the solution a lot of us
consume the cheap Goods the Working Poor
produce a lot of us are invested in the
stock market don't we benefit when our
savings go up even if that savings comes
at a human sacrifice many of us benefit
from tax breaks
and we don't think of those as welfare
programs but they are they cost the
government money and they put money in
our pocket and you know uh a lot of us
hold on to those tax breaks which starve
anti-poverty spending and then we have
the audacity to ask how can we afford to
do more as a country so I think that
when you start looking at the poverty
Problem by looking at the fire you kind
of realize there's so much poverty in
America not in spite of our wealth but
because of it and I think that opens up
new possibilities for change I'm
interested in your thoughts about to
what degree there is Moral Moral
responsibility at the individual
decision level maybe this is analogous
too you know I've talked with my
audience before uh about how if you
think taxes should be higher uh sending
the IRS more money isn't really policy
it's not a solution to the problem it's
not how we got here and so you can
simultaneously
hey I think pay what you legally owe
while advocating that large swaths of
people may be including yourself should
be paying more if we apply that to the
conversation that we're having about
poverty
how should the individual look at their
level of responsibility here
I think we should commit ourselves
becoming poverty abolitionists you know
we should view poverty not as a
unfortunate aspect of American life but
as an abomination
and I think like other abolitionist
movements to move into abolish slavery
the prison you know we should recognize
that profiting from someone else's pain
corrupts all of us
and so that's a that's a political
project that's going to take renewed
political movements and policies but it
also is a personal project and that
requires us to shop differently invest
differently thinking about taxes you
know for those of us that benefit from
this lopsided welfare state the fact
that the country does so much more to
guard fortunes than to fight poverty
maybe we start a letter writing campaign
we write our Congress person saying like
let's wind down these things I don't
need this this is also a neighbor to
neighbor conversation over the fence
line conversation not because you know
these little kind of personal moves will
abolish poverty but those personal moves
multiplied over and over again builds a
political will that empowers our
lawmakers to act one of the areas that's
a topic of much much discussion with
lawmakers and in communities and with
neighbors is about zoning practices
approval boards for condos restricted
income condos all these different things
can we talk a little bit about that in
the sense of you know we we know about
the long history of exclusionary zoning
practices practices in lending many of
us have talked about those realities we
now sometimes see I mean recently in
Brooklyn I was talking with some friends
about a project that was putting in I
think it was a dozen or so units and the
idea is we're going to sell the Dozen
units to six buyers and these are going
to be income limited so everybody buys
two units you live in one we create
lower income landlords it all sounds
interesting but is it really going to
are we really going to deal with this
problem
piecemeal in that way or does the
solution really have to come from higher
and be broader and bigger
yeah I think both and everything all the
above you know and I think that
segregation continues to be a driving
force of poverty in America there's
probably no more soulless phrase in the
English language than Municipal zoning
ordinance you know but like that's a
really good way to look at the soul of a
community you know on 75 percent of our
land you can only build a single
detached family home you know we build
these walls around our community and we
hoard affluence behind those walls and
that not only concentrates wealth but it
concentrates poverty outside of our
walls so we have to tear down the Walls
we have to start reaching for broader
inclusive communities which really means
you know going down to your zoning board
meeting at Tuesday night and standing up
and saying look I refuse to deny kids
opportunities my kids get living in this
place we got to build this thing I
refuse to be a segregationist so again
here's a conversation that sounds very
like policy and Abstract yeah but it's
also very personal you know it's about
how we vote how we move the
conversations we're having with our
workers at the water cooler you know and
studies show that you know Democrats are
more likely to embrace affordable
housing than abstract but are no more
likely than conservatives to vote Yes in
their own backyards you know studies
show that conservative renters were
actually more likely to vote Yes on an
affordable housing project than liberal
homeowners so I think our values cannot
stop where our property line begins we
really have to live out these values in
our own lives how do those values apply
or connect to just to pick something
that's often discussed to get your take
on it something like mobile phones and
in in particular in the context of
activism most of us have heard that and
are aware that mobile phones are
connected to so-called conflict minerals
typically from other countries we're now
talking outside the U.S even though
companies like apple and others will say
no everything's fine we're ensuring this
that the other thing isn't going on
videos have surfaced where we see that
there are very young young looking
people hard to say they aren't kids
digging by hand Etc then they're
manufactured they're sold in places like
you know a T-Mobile store Apple Store in
the United States right and we can look
at the wages that are paid there and
they're not astronomic likely high but
they're sort of like okay and a lot of
these are creating local jobs Etc in the
United States how do we take that
Panorama total and combine it with the
fact that many people who want to be
activists for exactly the issues you're
talking about use the devices to to that
end right so it also plays a role in
their activism how do we unwind
something so seemingly seemingly
complicated when we apply the sort of
standard and critique you're applying
yeah I would love us to apply that kind
of critique to Poverty abolitionism you
know many of us know uh not to eat
chocolate from certain brands because of
these things or we are aware of the
climate consequences of certain
purchases or flights or certain meals
but you know we know that our our
cucumbers it's local organic we don't
know how much the farm hand-picked it we
know where to get our coffee if we want
to Signal certain political values but
we don't ask how much the workers are
getting paid in there I was in in London
a few weeks ago and I saw these stickers
on stores and they said you know we play
we pay a living wage and I went into a
store and I said what tell me about the
sticker and they're like well you know
the standard is here but you know our
company's decided to bring it up to here
I would love to see that kind of thing
happening in America that consumer push
and process and so there's groups like
Union Plus that say Hey you know you
want a candy bar you want a beer these
are these are union made these aren't
and there's organizations like b-core
that says you know these companies have
really high standards of environmental
and social uh Consciousness they pay
their workers well and so I think that
like shopping and investing a little bit
in solidarity with the poor makes a lot
of sense as you as the cell phone
example relates right a lot of us kind
of feel
you know embroiled in these kind of
morally compromising networks and we
want out of it you know and this is
where kind of an argument for poverty
abolition isn't just an argument for the
end of this depravity and scarcity it's
about a Freer country a safer country a
happier country in a country where we
don't worry so much about our kids you
know I was I was in London a couple
weeks ago as well and saw the exact same
stickers and and found them interesting
should we be economic nationalists in
this conversation in the sense of
prioritizing for example like with
coffee there's very little coffee grown
in the US I think maybe some in Hawaiian
that's basically it so it's coming from
other parts of the world in having this
conversation should we be economic
nationalists in the sense of focusing on
the metrics that relate to the workers
in the U.S or should we be considering
the farm in Costa Rica or wherever and
then with coffee there's a middle person
that's often involved where sometimes a
lot of that money actually gets sucked
in to what degree should we focus on
within the U.S versus outside of it I
think there is an there is something to
be said by starting here and the reason
is building a political will to abolish
poverty in America and I I mean that for
real you know I think we can and should
end poverty in this land of abundance
getting to that goal I think motivates
further investments in countries that
have far more poverty in the United
States and and could could get us there
but if we can't do it here right in our
own backyard I don't think we have a
chance of doing it abroad so I don't
think we have to choose and I think that
often we have these kind of scarcity
arguments right where we're kind of
setting up this false scarcity narrative
I don't think we have to do it but I
think just pragmatically there is
something to be said about okay let's
tackle poverty right here right now then
let's broaden broaden the aperture last
thing I wanted to ask you about um
particularly in the context of the Comet
coveted stimulus bills the Earned Income
Tax Credit has been a topic of
discussion um I I think generally
speaking it's a good program I like the
higher numbers I think it makes sense in
a lot of ways but it also has
limitations which which you've talked
about certainly it doesn't seem to
address the root causes of poverty and
the reasons people might qualify for an
earned uh Earned Income Tax Credit child
tax credit to to begin with can you talk
a little bit about that treating symptom
versus disease Maybe
right so the earn income tax credit is
kind of a wage subsidy that our poorest
paid workers many of them parents get
every year it's a big part of the safety
net it's about 61 billion dollars a year
and for a lot of families man it's a
lifesaver you know it is a lifesaver it
lifts millions of families out of
poverty
uh but it doesn't address that problem
that low wage problem do I think the
eitc is a good idea do we need it
absolutely do I think that we need other
things that really cut at the root of
poverty yes so those would be things
like worker power uh expanding uh
representation on corporate boards for
example for workers yes finding out ways
of making organizing easy instead of
this incredibly hard slow process that
it is now things to really kind of build
up uh wages and fight worker
exploitation and you know as we're doing
that let's definitely make sure those
families have enough to get by with
things like the eitc so short-term
Solutions and long-term Solutions do you
see that Democrats or Republicans are
definitively better on this issue or is
that a lot of political Framing and
posturing when there may not be as much
daylight as some would believe
no I think Democrats are definitely
better on this issue fair I think on the
ground level there's a lot of Americans
that want this right most Americans want
a higher minimum wage most Americans
think the rich aren't paying their fair
share taxes yes most Democrats and most
Republican voters think poverty now is a
relative unfair circumstances not a
moral failing so I think there's a lot
of us on the ground level neighbor to
neighbor that actually agree on these
basic issues of economic justice but our
electives are polarized from us and
that's a problem that we need to fix the
book is poverty by America we've been
speaking with the book's author
Professor Matt Desmond sociology
department at Princeton University
really appreciate your time and insights
thank you David appreciate you